Michels in Phoenix Arizona hi Michelle
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thanks for taking my call
sure what's up um well my husband and I
had gone through a financial piece about
a year ago and we've gotten rid of at
least one credit card and however my
husband decided to take a whole
different route with his life and we'll
be divorcing oh and so you know I
understand that I've got to give them
half my 401k and you know our debts
we'll take half of the debt so my whole
was me a little bit because now I have
you know half my debts gone but when we
found the house my question is is when
we sell the house and I get my portion
of the profit should I put that in an
account and wait and see if I'm also
going to be moving I'm going to be
moving actually out of state to another
state put that in their account so that
I got a new job set up and everything
yeah yeah I got a job set up children at
home I have two children
yeah home we're going wage they're going
with me yeah he's paying child support
yeah he'll be Jane will be Jane paying
child support and alimony
no no alimony in either direction okay
so when I move I'll actually probably
have about a year of rent trees because
I'll be living with my parents until
they move back up to a different
location so I'm looking should I put
that money aside until I ready to go buy
a house if I've got a nice chunk of
money you know I'm not using it what not
now or should I put that to my debt I'm
thinking I could you know some of it
could grow at a faster rate it being put
aside you know and I you know in some
type of an account to grow it a little
bit or sure just put it to pay down the
debt and and work you know continue to
work the process your your situation
makes you more vulnerable and more
scared but it doesn't change the
principles okay and so I would walk you
right up our baby steps but first thing
I would do is say let's don't do any of
this until you get moved and get settled
right I want that money available to
make sure you and your kids have a
solid foundation to restart from that's
that's first and foremost you get the
new job you're not worried about lights
or water or food and you get your
monthly budget back with an income back
in a rhythm again okay and okay now we
can live on what I make and with the
child support we can live on that and
here's how we can pay rent when mom and
dad come back we got to go rent us a
little house and once you get the rhythm
of all of that laid out that may take
you six months I really don't want you
to spend any of this money I just don't
want it invested and I don't want to pay
it on debt until you get stabilized I
would just pile it up over there in the
corner just in case kind of fund it's on
one lady called it orgy okay fund god
only knows okay you know and that kind
of thing and it's just sitting there for
right now
please don't spend it oh please keep
your hands off of it because you're
going to need it but I but but just in
case you guys I don't want you having no
debt and no money for groceries right
because your income hasn't started yet
or something silly like that now how
much will you receive from the house
your PHA it'll it will probably be about
ten to fifteen thousand and how much
debt do you have your part my part is
it'll be about thirty thousand okay plus
and actually in February also get a
bonus check which should be about ten to
fifteen thousand okay so and then with
those two I could pay off all the debt
and be done I know that wasn't the
numbers you gave me you said you had
thirty thousand and dead in ten thousand
what correct ten thousand four thousand
fifteen thousand did you say fifteen
thousand and bonus in thousand five
that's not 30 but it's close okay what
it doesn't do it no no but I'd be able
to do it within the next couple of
months assuming your income is
stabilized correct you have that job
lined up yeah okay what will you be
making I'll be making a little bit less
than I'm making now I make 115 now I'll
be making about probably 108 that's also
when I hide okay cool well that gives
you real that that's a that's a
wonderful part of the story right there
okay so we've got that in child support
we're going to throw everything slick
wood once you get up there get
stabilized and get settled into a
how's everything that's liquid the bonus
check the money coming from the sale the
house any other monies you get from
anywhere at the debt until the debt is
gone then you build your emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses
just like we taught you in FP you then
you'll start in saving for a house if
you want to buy a home and then you'll
start baby step that's baby step 3b we
call it baby step four then is you'll
restart your at that time you'll restart
your 401k until then you don't add to
your retirement I wouldn't cash out any
retirement but I would not add anything
to it until you get through those other
steps just exactly like we taught you
but the only the only caveat the only
difference is we're going to do nothing
for a little while on purpose until we
get past the heartbreak of this and the
the instability the volatility of all
the crap flying around in your life
right now right and sometimes just have
a little money piled up in the corner
makes that a little easier to walk
through it doesn't heal a broken heart
but it makes it easier to walk through
the crap you know what I'm saying oh yes
I understand and that's that's all I'm
telling you to do rather than being
broke on top of the broken heart that
makes it double bad in other words so
the good news is you got a fabulous
income lined up and you're going to be
okay from that standpoint now the debts
that are left in that he is taking are
they exclusively in his name or is your
name on them um actually they are
exclusively in his name good the one
debt that I'm taking is in both of our
names perfect so I'm I'm responsible for
that one so yeah I didn't want to give
that with him exactly and that way if he
decides to go off the ranch on his
finances as well then you know and I'm
not impacted and you're not impacted
you're not going to go back and pay
something that the divorce decree said
you weren't supposed to pay but the law
says you're still owe so you don't have
that problem because you're getting rid
of the house and anything with your name
on it you're taking responsibility for
anyway so this is a very clean
transaction or if we don't count the
heart great sorry you're going through
this Michele thank you thank you thank
you for your break and I really
appreciate it
if we can help you any further you let
us know we're here for you kiddo you
know why most people don't win they
don't bother you have to bother it to be
intentional never again as American
Express is going to call my house and
ask my wife why she
would stay with a man that won't pay his
bills